hello everybody this is gary vaynerchuk
and today is november 15th and this is
my 120 and i've got two big things to
talk about let's first go to the uk
where it looks like our prince harry
three-year relationship with chelsea
davey
has come to an end and is it because the
paparazzi you know
the mirror and the star out there have
caught him cheating on the side
uh-uh this is more about new technology
and how it's changing our world more and
more every day and people are not
realizing it
this is an instance of him texting a
little flirty flirty action to somebody
on the side
and she getting wind of it it's
unbelievable but if nothing else what
you should realize
is that technology has changed our
worlds and there is no privacy
all of us you me all of us we are now
part of
the paparazzi world anybody can be
caught doing anything now you do
anything
it is probably being caught and it's
gonna probably get worse but what's next
is there gonna be a google bot in my
brain and if i see a pretty girl my
wife's gonna know about it
the world's changing recognize part two
and this is something that's really kind
of interesting you hate to kind of
pee on somebody who did something nice
to you for you excuse me
but cnn did a nice story on wine 2.0 and
gave me a big spread and big feature
and i kind of was interested because
somebody emailed me about four hours
after the story was released i was like
how did i not know about this well
that's because
cnn was not sending any traffic to wine
library tv because they weren't
linking us up as a matter of fact more
importantly there's three or four other
small
sites that could really use the traffic
and they didn't link to them either and
so
it got me thinking i did a little
homework talk to some of my boys alex
html and you know what
they said that they've gotten some big
stories from mainstream media and never
got any link love
hey mainstream media what are you
thinking i mean what what
what you know time magazine i had a beg
for my link i mean
this is why you're mainstream and not
hip and not cool because you gotta give
to get it was nice to see the wall
street journal adding dig buttons
as an example of a bigger company may be
starting to get it you don't want to
give love
you're not going to get any love i'll
end you with that